bake the basics for cloud storage bytes be
inspected buckets
in this episode title also an elephant
has a package in patcher performance
of gotham is an optimizer storage
just like all times
santini giro where is a kind of bytes what
have [ __ ] it should be using for the
best  performance and as whiskas
previously
cloud storage the fourth pack
options reign [ __ ] quick retrieval
multiple focus on multi regional and
regional package for query fresh what that
means and regional cloud storage box
guarantees the altera in a park in light
and
espresso factory  input and in situations where you
know where required to run from systems
and located and you wanna be your just
bought it as close to those client
systems as possible
motives fast storage on the other hand
it guarantees you work as a beauty
booster gio die vers dat  less a
minimum of 100 times support this may
result in therapy must be between regions
for better latency and de  many billy
murder diner motor emergency kit heavily
leverage eye-catching en sapiens for by
the content and users to alice reese a
real-life scenarios and better
understand how the passengers more exciting
stress
positive test uploaded to make a while
to a bunch of guys know and multitool
budgets  and investor a set with chain
disabled
from me via men us with my week on duty
franchise here firstly
patches and miss amy reid and organic a
breach and op de multivision
perform fries all die justice would
expect but when fishing for regional
this brief parfumerie where you  will
lead you notice the trappers part time and
this is hot altiris emergency kit shine at
that attempt nakida 2 gio die were three
without fast is case in the instance bed
live id be much closer the final
destination
you already see idrops and or
init-preset  efficient the biggest widow
here is that there is snow specific
performance also of the classification
of the package stem cells the
performance  dominated by the latency and physical
distance between the client and the
cloud storage package superb reply
caching check if you acces
william islam in all i get the better
yet and performance government is reverend
primarily by physics
here you will in your music on the a6 close
to the client est possible
training af wizard is not the red
custard en en sea and  consistency
the tension is chewing optimizing
performance coordinative peper and cfr
nether episodes
if you'd like to know more go ahead in
jakarta links in the description and
don't forget to subscribe
you were a like and the would is half a
million dollars an app  google cloud
storage
do you think for joining is for so click
or cloud storage
see you next time
[Music]